bonsoir connaissez-vous george orwell
si vous avez assidus
au cours de français vous devriez
connaître 1984 il s'agit d' une dystopie
pour ceux qui dorment au fond de la
classe
une dystopie c'est quoi c'est un univers
qui semble parfait au premier abord mais
qui finalement ne l'est pas vraiment ce
livre parle notamment de big brother
il s'agit d'une demande une entité
colossal qui sait absolument tout de ce
que vous dites fait
regardez et écoutez on pourrait se dire
que l'année 1984 est finalement passé
que rien de tel n'existe et que nous
vivons dans une société parfaite où nos
libertés sont préservés cependant en
2020 on a quand même par exemple la nsa
aux états unis prenez aussi l'exemple de
la chine
le gouvernement a récemment mis en place
un système de notation qui permet en
fonction de vos bonnes et mauvaises
actions d'établir un score qui aura
directement un impact sur vos vies par
exemple l'achat d'une voiture une
demande de prêt les études que vous
souhaiterez réaliser ou le métier que
vous souhaiterez effectués ça fait
beaucoup quand est il de la france
en france on à l'e-réputation c'est
votre identité numérique une seconde
identité
j'ai pu théorisé l'e-réputation à ma
manière mais avant ça je vais vous
donner quelques exemples pour illustrer
justement comment l'e-réputation cette
deuxième identité numérique va avoir un
impact de plus en plus graves sur vos
vie que vous soyez particulier
entrepreneurs personnalités publiques
tout le monde est concerné donc suivez
bien premier exemple
cette étudiante qui a réussi à avoir un
stage à la nasa il ya quelques années
cette histoire elle est assez connu
parfait pour elle va pouvoir voyager sur
la lune voyager dans l'espace et rendre
un magnifique rapport de stage elle
s'est donc empressé de le tweet est en
ajoutant quelques injures au passage
pour exprimer sa joie
on a décidé de les cacher un internaute
décide de la mettre en garde sur sa
manière de parler assez logique eh bien
on a décidé de le remettre à sa place en
insistant sur le fait qu'elle avait
réussi à voir son stage à la nasa
mais le problème c'est que l'internaute
en question c'était en fait un
intervenant
un membre de l'organisme qui supervise
la nasa
résultat des courses stage perdu
deuxième exemple cette fois ci en france
je suppose que vous avez déjà tous
contacts et un service client admettons
que votre box ne marche plus vous allez
appeler un numéro souvent payant est
surtaxé quelqu'un va vous répondre au
bout du fil
eva voulu l'aider avec un long processus
script et l'un d'entre eux a eu
l'excellente idée de se moquer sur
twitter du processus de son entreprise
qui fut justement trop lent trop long et
trop lourd
son employeur tombe sur le contenu et
décide de le réprimander logique c'est
comme si vous étiez en fait dans la rue
que vous marchez avec votre employeur
que vous décidiez devant tout le monde
ouvertement de critiquer votre
entreprise en tout cas le processus de
l'entreprise
il doit pas forcément être content et
bien notre internaute en question notre
internaute préféré il a quant à lui
décidé de se plaindre de nouveau sur
twitter en comporte en critiquant le
comportement justement big brother de
son entreprise et de son employeur celui
ci tombe de nouveau sur le contenu
puisqu'il avait à la base son compte
twitter ce qui est logique et décide
cette fois de le mettre à pied encore un
impact sur une vie de particuliers
d'ailleurs selon une enquête mcafee 7 %
des français ont déjà été licenciés
après que l'employeur soit tombé sur un
de leurs postes c'est comme 7%
les personnalités publiques sont elles
aussi concernées par ces problématiques
premier exemple le cas de la ferme enel
tout le monde connaît c'était une
candidate qui avait tout pour aller loin
dans l'émission voir remporter ce vote
des internautes se sont penché du côté
de son nid réputation et sont tombés sur
d'anciens postes facebook datant de 2016
donc deux ans avant l'émission dans
laquelle en fait elle critiquait le
gouvernement et son rapport avec les
attentats terroristes de l'époque
malgré ses excuses et son jeune âge au
moment des postes elle avait quand même
16 ans à l'époque elle obligée
d'abandonner les missions deuxième
exemple
cette fois ci aux états unis kevin hart
un excellent comédien humoriste
américain qui a joué dans des films
comme think like a man par exemple au
sommet de sa gloire il ya deux ans il
devait présenter les oscars en 2019
d'anciens tweet datant des années 2010
ont été retrouvés ont été exhumés et ont
eu un impact en fait sur sa carrière
parce que il ne pourra finalement pas
présenter les oscars et l'histoire
continuera de le suivre des années et
des mois plus tard par exemple l'été
dernier il a eu un grave accident de
voiture dans lequel il a failli perdre
la vie bien figurez vous que les médias
pour parler de lui continué de le
décrire comme l'ancien humoriste
américain dont d'anciens tweet n'ont
empêché en fait de présenter les oscars
donc on pourrait légitimement se
demander finalement combien de temps
encore cette réputation numérique passer
cette identité numérique passé aura un
impact sur son identité actuelle est
réel
avant de passer à la partie théorique
dernier exemple est cette fois ci c'est
mon préféré un certain politicien
français a été accusé entre autres
d'organiser des dîners onéreux avec de
l'argent public
sa ligne de défense c'était je n'aime
pas le champagne et je n'aime pas les
fruits de mer et bien des internautes
assez malins ont réussi à retrouver
d'anciens tweet dans lesquels en fait
ils disaient qu'ils avaient adoré les
huîtres et le champagne acheté la veille
entre autres c'est assez drôle n'y aura
pas forcément d'impact dans un procès
potentiel mais ça va clairement le
décrédibiliser comment paraître sérieux
auprès des français
après cette histoire qu'est-ce que
l'e-réputation finalement passons à la
partie théorique
j'ai pu la théoriser en trois dimensions
la première représente tout ce que vous
avez pu poster ça va être vos tweets
post facebook commentaires facebook
commentaires sur des sites des forums
des blogs etc
tout ce que vous avez pu rédiger vous
avez eu votre première connexion à
l'époque dao elle est bien votre
e-réputation a commencé au moment où
vous avez lancé votre premier profil sur
le forum de votre film préféré imaginer
la quantité de données que ça peut
représenter la deuxième partie ça
représente ce qui a été postée sur vous
donc par exemple les photos de soirées
facebook sur les murs de vos amis ou des
amis de vos amis aussi ça peut être les
articles sur différents sites par
exemple lorsque vous avez eu votre
baccalauréat
maintenant vous apparaissez sur un
certains sites vous avez le droit de
faire supprimer ces contenus là par
exemple pour les fautes et de soirée
vous avez juste à contacter vos amis ou
les amis de vos amis pour faire
supprimer ce contenu pour les sites
c'est un peu plus long c'est possible
mais un peu plus long par exemple vous
pouvez tenter le déréférencement sur
groupe
pour ne plus apparaître dans les
recherches google ensuite vous pouvez
contacter directement le propriétaire du
site
s'il ne répond pas ça veut peut-être
dire que le site a été laissé à
l'abandon
vous pouvez contacter l'hébergeur et
pour finir vous pouvez aussi contacter
la cnil qui met à disposition en fait un
formulaire de droit à l'oubli vous
pouvez par exemple insisté sur la
présence de données personnelles privé
au sein de l'article
mais n'oubliez pas que toutes ces étapes
prennent énormément de temps voilà pour
la partie théorique voilà pour les trois
dimensions de l'eréputation maintenant
je vais faire travailler un peu votre
imagination pour vous montrer comment
cette team réputation peut avoir de
l'impact sur la vie de chacun
on va imaginer c'est la plupart pour
l'instant le cas d'entre vous que vous
êtes étudiant en école de commerce
grande école de commerce vous êtes en
dernière année vous êtes passé les trois
dernières années avec succès vos examens
vos projets et vous avez passé aussi les
trois dernières années à faire un peu la
fête pour décompresser par exemple de la
prépa maintenant il va falloir trouver
votre stage de fin d'études en principe
ça devrait être facile
comme j'ai dit vous êtes d'une grande
école de commerce donc vous avez quand
même accès à un grand réseau avec pas
mal de contacts dans dé bonnes
entreprises
mais maintenant l'e-réputation va
rentrer en jeu dans le processus de
recrutement
d'ailleurs selon une enquête de yougov
c'est 80 % des entreprises qui ont déjà
analysé votre réputation qui ont déjà
analyser vos réseaux sociaux lors du
processus de recrutement et près de 30%
d'entre elles qui ont finalement refusé
votre candidature après être tombé sur
vos réseaux sociaux
donc presque une entreprise sur trois
comment font-elles pour analyser vos
réseaux sociaux
la première possibilité c'est quand il
n'y a pas forcément de budget elles font
une simple recherche google donc si vous
êtes un peu à l'heure sur le sujet vous
avez mis des adresses mails
professionnels et personnels différentes
vous avez mis vos réseaux sociaux en
privé et vous avez par exemple mis des
faux noms facebook ça peut marcher mais
lorsqu'elles ont un peu plus de budget
elles ont accès à deux ressources qui
sont bien plus effrayante
la première c'est les screenings
compagnie weiss a fait un excellent
article sur le sujet il s'agit de
sociétés mandatées par des services rh
pour analyser vos réseaux sociaux
c'est à dire qu'en fait elles vont
passer des semaines à éplucher vos
réseaux sociaux pour déterminer en
fonction
réputation si vous êtes employables ou
pas en fait c'est comme si l'entreprise
embauché un détective privé qui va vous
suivre dans la rue donc dans un lieu
public parce que rappelons le vos
réseaux sociaux la plupart du temps
c'est des lieux publics entre guillemets
et qui vont déterminer en fonction de
vos actions si vous êtes employables ou
pas est-ce que c'est éthique
à vous de voir la deuxième ressource
elle est bien plus effrayante
il s'agit des logiciels de people
searching comme le logiciel people ils
permettent aux entreprises clientes
d'avoir accès à toutes vos informations
sur internet avec très peu de données en
entrez votre adresse mail et ça permet
de reconstituer en fait la constellation
que forment vos réseaux sociaux vos
adresses mail numéro de téléphone
enregistré et ensuite avoir des
informations comme nom prénom ou est-ce
que vous habitez si vous avez des chats
des chiens si vous êtes célibataire dans
quelle langue vous twittez toutes ces
informations est long et il n'y a pas
que les entreprises qui ont accès à ces
informations là par exemple pour un
entrepreneur un banquier lorsque vous
allez demander un prêt pour votre
entreprise ou un partenaire commercial
qui voudra pas forcément s'associe avec
une personne qui a une mauvaise
réputation
n'oubliez pas que la question
d'électricité se pose certes mais que
tout ce que vous avez posté la plupart
du temps ces publics donc ces personnes
là vont se baser sur des données
publiques autre dérive
admettons que vous poster une photo sur
internet qui peut se retrouver sur des
sites pour adultes
c'est un risque là encore n'oubliez pas
que ces photos continue de vous
appartenir malgré la légende urbaine qui
disent qu'une fois que vous avez posté
une photo sur internet
elle ne vous appartient plus et faut par
contre elle devient public
ça veut dire que des personnes tierces
peuvent les réutiliser et il faudra
demander à chaque fois à ces personnes
de les faire supprimer ça peut être
assez non donc mon conseil c'est de
maîtriser ce que vous postez de poster
en connaissance de cause et limiter les
données personnelles que vous donnez
finalement à des tiers une autre bonne
idée serait aussi de mettre ces
informations en privé ses réseaux
sociaux en privé mais à voir ces réseaux
sociaux en public peut avoir de bonnes
répercussions finalement ça peut avoir
des avantages
si vous êtes une personnalité publique
vous pouvez par exemple agrandir votre
communauté
si vous êtes un commercial ou un
entrepreneur vous pouvez vendre vos
produits
c'est intéressant et si vous êtes un
particulier par exemple à la recherche
d'opportunités professionnelles
vous pouvez très bien l'utiliser comme
un complément de cv parce que ça va
servir à humaniser votre candidature
votre employeur pour savoir quel est
votre film préféré si vous avez de
l'humour et c est finalement peut-être
potentiellement faciliter votre
intégration à l'entreprise mais d'autres
dérives peuvent encore exister on peut
penser à la récente loi qui permet au
fisc d'analysé en temps réel vos réseaux
sociaux comptent airbnb le bon coin pour
savoir si vous fraudé ou pas deuxième
fraude deuxième ronde deuxième dérive ça
peut être lorsque vous faites votre
demande maintenant de visa pour les
etats-unis j'ai pas mal de clients qui
viennent me voir en disant bon bah je
vais partir pour les états unis
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire parce que
maintenant lorsque vous demandez votre
visa le gouvernement est capable de
demander l'accès à vos réseaux sociaux
pour analyser en fonction de votre
e-réputation toujours si vous pouvez
voyager ou non aux états unis donc ça
veut dire que ça serait quand même bête
que pour un tweet posté quand vous aviez
13 ou 14 ans en 2015 2016
vous pourriez pas passer vos vacances à
miami ou à new york
donc il faut faire extrêmement attention
d'autres dérives pourront arriver avec
le temps on pourrait potentiellement
penser à l'assurance maladie qui
pourrait vérifier en fonction de vos
posts sur instagram si vous êtes en
vacances ou chez vous pendant votre
arrêt maladie
une autre dérive qui pourrait arriver à
terme c'est les assurances plus
classique qui se baserait aussi sur vos
postes instagram facebook twitter pour
déterminer votre état de santé et
ensuite définir si vous avez droit telle
offre ou telle offre pour l'assurance
maladie
est ce que ça vous rappelle pas big
brother finalement on va terminer en
analysant mains propres e-réputation
assez rapidement pour voir en quelques
clics à quelles données on peut accéder
sur moi si je tape malik agar surtout
sur google je vais tomber sur mon profil
linkedin
pas de problème en principe il est comme
propres je vais vous ravoir que je
travaille pour une certaines entreprises
si je travaille si je tape ce nom de
cette certaines entreprises sur google
je vais pouvoir accès par exemple au
compte twitter de l'entreprise en ayant
accès au compte twitter de l'entreprise
je peux tout simplement copier coller le
nom de l'entreprise dans la barre de
recherche google pour savoir ce qui se
dit
cette entreprise est tombé sur mon
profil twitter qui n'a absolument rien à
voir avec mon nom de famille c'est à
calais 1914
ça n'a rien à voir pourtant on y aient
accès en quelques clics on pourrait se
dire que je devais peut-être mettre mes
réseaux sociaux en privé mais ça me sert
quand même pour promouvoir mon activité
en tapant à quel 914 sur google on tombe
sur mon compte instagram et là on peut
voir que par exemple j'adore tout ce qui
est mal bouffe et là une assurance à
terme et pour l'asie rebond bas il n'a
pas l'air d'avoir un excellent état de
santé on va peut mais on va peut-être
lui mettre le package plus plus au cas
où
donc voilà en quelques clics tout ce
qu'on peut retrouver sur moi à moi de
faire attention à tout ce que je poste
tout ce que j'ai pu poster et tout ce
qui se dit pour moi sur moi afin d'être
le plus au work safe possible c'est ce
qu'on appelle on appelle ça worksafe est
aussi avoue finalement de faire appel
par exemple à des sociétés spécialisées
à faire attention à tous vos réseaux
sociaux à ce que vous avez pu poster et
vous refaire une santé numérique parce
que n'oubliez pas souriez vous êtes
observé
[Applaudissements]